moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui dans le
débat public et politique
après le choc de cette élection de 2017
et des élections de emmanuel macron les
partis traditionnels j'ai pas besoin de
beaucoup mais tendre pour considérer
qu'ils sont dans une grande difficulté
le parti socialiste en particulier bon à
partir là il ya deux ans je le premier
c'est effectivement d'adapter de
renouveler de changer les parties et le
parti socialiste en particulier j'en ai
pris d'engagement et je pense que c'est
le premier point mais on ne peut le
faire que si on est à nouveau entendu
parce qu'un parti politique n'a de sens
que lorsqu'il présente des candidats et
candidates aux élections et qu'il y ait
des électeurs qui viennent voter
donc si on n'a pas cette double
stratégie et si on n'a qu'une stratégie
on n'arrivera pas au bout à redresser
relevé un parti qui connaît aujourd'hui
des difficultés
c'est pourquoi je pense que ce qui est
souvent critiquée ou qui met souvent
reproché d'expérience que j'ai le fait
que j'ai été porte parole
ça peut au contraire être un atout et je
le considère comme tel pour pouvoir
justement faire les deux à la fois et
rénové et adapté le parti socialiste et
en même temps existé dans le débat
public
le roi vous estimez que vos concurrents
et notamment olivier faure qui
fait un peu figure de favori aujourd'hui
ne sont pas assez charismatique ne vont
pas porter assez fortement la joie des
jeunes je vais pas faire de commentaire
sur les autres candidats je pense que
j'ai une capacité à porter cette voie et
cette voix du parti socialiste de ce
parti entre jean luc mélenchon et la
république en marche et que c'est un des
enjeux de ce congrès oui mais sinon je
quelle aurait été la justification de ma
candidature c'est pas un problème de
compétence sur le fond c'est pas un
problème
par exemple pour une idée fort qui
aurait été de 2,2 d'avoir été front deux
roues pas c'est pas le sujet c'est pas
parce que c'est pas la vérité il a été
tout à fait loyal et il était proche de
jean marc ayrault au début du
quinquennat et il est resté loyal tout
au long du quinquennat j'ai voté pour
olivier faure pour le groupe
lorsqu'on est arrivé j'avais même
soutenu à la fin du quinquennat
donc je n'ai là-dessus aucun sujet je
considère simplement quelles sont les
questions qui nous sont posées et
comment on irait de bon je pense que je
peux apporter dans les deux ans qui
viennent
parce que pour moi le reste et la suite
c'est pas le sujet prioritaire c'est à
dire 2022 dans les deux ans qui viennent
alors qu'il ya des élections européennes
qui est difficile et qui a des
municipales qu'on doit préparer objectif
municipal il faut qu'on puisse aller
vite et se donner cette force rapidement
et danic rapidement voilà pourquoi je
considère que ma candidature à une
justification tout casser